This is Jocko podcast number one 78 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo that evening.
Okay.
Honorable Mother and father.
Yeah.
The difficulty of the journey you made to see me was clearly evident in your
disheveled hair and in the hollows under your eyes.
It made me want to bend my knees and worship before you
in the wrinkles on your brows was vivid testimony of the pains you took to raise
me.
Words could not express my feelings and what little I did say with superficial
in the extreme.
Yeah.
Yet,
although acutely conscious of how little time we had,
I saw on your eyes and in your gaze all you wanted to say but couldn't
when you took my hand.
I experienced a sense of profound peacefulness unlike anything I've experienced
since joining up,
like being a baby again and longing for the warmth of a mother's love.
Okay.
It is because I bask in the beauty of your deep devotion that I can martyr
myself for you
foreign death.
I will sleep in the world of your love,
honorable mother.
Even if I was never able to fully accept the love you gave me,
I received so much wisdom from you
and father,
your silent words are carved deeply into my heart.
With this,
I will be able to fight together with both of you,
even if I should die.
It will be with a peaceful spirit.
I mean this with all my heart.
The war zone is where these beautiful emotions are put to the test.
Yeah.
If death means a return to this world of love,
there is no need for me to fear.
There is nothing left to do,
but press on then fulfill my duty.
Okay.
And that is the final letter written by a man named captain,
uh,
Daci
okay.
To Korea,
who's written obviously to his parents,
and he was assigned to kamikaze special attack group number one.
And he did carry out his mission,
a suicide attack on one of the u s navy vessels,
the vicinity of Okinawa on the 28th of April,
1945 he was 23 years old,
which is actually pretty old for a kamikaze.
Here's another last letter home.
This one's from ensign.
Kiyoshi.
Ogawa no father and mother.
It has been decided that I also will make a sorority as a proud,
as special attack core member.
Yeah.
Looking back,
when I think of your raising me in your arms for more than 20 years,
I am filled with a sense of gratitude.
Yeah.
I truly believe that no one else has lived a happier life than me and I am
resolved to repay the emperor and my father for your kindness.
Beyond those boundless white clouds,
I will make my attack with a calm feeling.
Okay.
Not even thoughts of life and death will come to my mind.
A person dies once.
It will be an honorable day to live for the eternal cause.
Father and mother,
please be glad for me,
okay.
Above all,
mother,
please take care of your health and I wish for everyone's prosperity.
Okay.
Father and mother,
I always and forever will be living near you and we'll be praying.
I will go smiling both on the day of my sorority and forever.
Okay.
Ben Ensign Ogawa was the pilot pilot of the second plane to hit the USS Bunker
hill
and that kamikaze attack killed 393 in wounded 264 and took the aircraft carrier
out of commission for the duration of the war.
Okay.
Most of the comma cozzies were young.
They were sometimes 17,
but usually 18,
19,
maybe 20 years old.
They all wrote final letters home.
Yeah.
The letters generally spoke of their commitment to the emperor,
their commitment to the Japan,
their commitment to their parents and it's actually theirs.
Theirs.
Yeah.
There's a lot of these letters.
There's thousands of them in.
It's,
it's actually when you sit there and read them,
it's actually kind of sickening to read these letters.
These young boys there.
Yeah.
Oh,
there are brainwashed.
And I know some people find some,
some level of honor in the kamikaze pilots.
You know,
they sacrifice for their country.
They,
they put service above themselves for their emperor.
Um,
I've a hard time with that.
These are kids,
right?
These are pawns.
And,
and actually they weren't even that effective.
They had a hit ratio of about 14%.
They,
there was 2,800 kamikaze pilots that were killed and they killed about 4,900
sailors,
US Navy,
sailors.
Okay.
And God bless all those brave sailors,
every one of those losses and deaths as a tragedy.
And the U s navy in World War II,
in the navy in general,
in World War II was a nightmare.
Uh,
the kamikaze sank 34 ships,
which is,
which is horrible,
but it actually wasn't a game changer.
But
these suicide bombers,
you've got to think about how they ended up in that situation.
And I don't like suicide bombers at all.
And I,
I guess I have a biased against suicide bombers.
Fine.
There was a lot of suicide bombers in Ramadi,
and some people,
like I said,
some people try and glorify a suicide bomber,
whether it's a kamikaze or whether it's a modern day suicide bomber.
And they try and glorify him,
but there's no glory.
The modern suicide bombers are either cowards that are afraid to face their
enemies in battle.
And what's really sad is that that's,
that's rare.
More than likely the modern suicide bomber that you're dealing with is an actual
victim himself who is,
you know,
usually a young kid been manipulated and lied to and,
and,
or,
or I should say also coerced through threats.
And that's,
that happened all the time.
It was like,
Hey,
if you don't carry out this suicide mission,
we're going to kill your family.
Yeah.
And so you might as well,
you might as well do it.
So that's what you're dealing with.
But some of them,
you know,
sometimes people just get straight up brainwashed.
And it's the same thing with the Japanese kamikaze.
He's a pro,
I would say a lot less on the coercion side.
You know,
like it wasn't like they were holding their family,
but they did a great job of,
of brainwashing this,
these kids.
And Yeah,
I'm no expert.
I should have said that straight out of the gate.
I'm just giving you my opinion,
my,
my thoughts about it.
There's some Japanese documents that I think paint a pretty clear picture of
kind of the,
the,
the foundation of what the Japanese military was taught.
Okay.
And it's why they were,
why they fought to the death.
And there's a lot of propaganda that you can look at to the propaganda that,
you know,
explains Americans as these evil people that we're going to come and rape their
women and news better to die.
So there's that.
But there's,
there's a more foundational thing I think,
um,
that that was printed in World War II and it was called the imperial rescript to
soldiers and sailors,
sailors,
and a rescript.
Is that an official guidance?
It's like this is the word from the boss and it included in,
it's something called the send Youcan,
which,
which meant instructions for the battlefield.
And what's weird about this document,
um,
is it's got a lot of really a lot of stuff in it that when you're here,
it sounds,
for lack of a better word,
it sounds good.
The kind of thing that you think,
oh wow,
that's,
that's honorable.
That's good.
It's very idealistic.
And,
and I think if this document,
this imperial rescript to soldiers and sailors,
if it actually would have been followed the,
a lot of the problems,
a lot of the atrocities that were committed,
we wouldn't have happened
because of the document as you're going to hear,
is a,
it's a fairly positive document.
And I think sometimes people take and they hold up that attitude,
that kind of Bushido attitude.
I'd hold it up on a pedestal.
And like I said,
I get it because when you,
when you look at it on its own,
you think,
wow,
this is,
this is a good thing.
This is a positive thing.
But what you can't forget is that it's this attitude of this attitude and this
culture of extreme obedience,
right?
Extreme obedience.
I talk all the time about how you got a question,
a question,
your leaders,
right?
And I talk all the time how if,
if you're told to do something that's unethical or illegal or immoral,
it is your obligation and your duty to disobey.
So they,
they didn't have that attitude.
Their attitude was 100% obedience.
They also had the strong attitude of ethnic superiority.
So they,
the Japanese people thought that their race and their ethnicity was superior to
everyone else's.
And that attitude led to things like these comics,
kamikaze pilots,
and it led to atrocities like the rape of Nanking and like unit seven,
31,
uh,
just horror,
horror show atrocities with the darkest evil imaginable
and know podcast 60 rape,
a Nan king podcast one 30 through one 33,
unit seven 31.
If you listen to those,
you don't,
you can't listen to those and feel normal when you're done listening to it.
You can't,
it's,
they're disturbing to listen to when you see how evil human beings can be to
other human beings.
So
like I said,
when you hear this imperial rescript
okay,
it,
it sounds positive.
A lot of it sounds good,
but it,
first of all,
it wasn't followed
cause some,
some of the positive parts of the code that they clearly did not listen to.
And then other parts of the code
that are positive,
like anything that's positive.
If you let it go too far,
then it becomes a negative.
And that's seems to me what happened,
at least in some sense,
an imperial Japan.
So I think this document kind of reveals how they framed their mindset.
And there's,
like I said,
there's lessons in here to learn and think about things that you can take away
that you say,
hmm,
that's a good policy.
But yeah.
Yeah.
You can also see that when it's taken to the extreme,
it becomes the framework for imperial Japan to become the sadistic evil that
they originally believed that they were fighting against.
So let's get into it.
The imperial rescript to soldiers and sailors,
sailors.
Here we go.
Introduction.
The battle is aware.
The imperial army acting under the imperial command displays its true character
conquering whenever it attacks winning whenever and engages in combat in order
to spread Codo.
And so Kodo is the imperial way.
That's what it means.
And that's the,
that's how they describe it.
But what's interesting is it,
it literally means like a fragrance,
like a smell.
So it's like the scent,
the spirit,
the heartbeat.
So that's what Kodo is.
They want to spread the Koto far and wide so that the enemy may look up in awe
to the August verse,
virtues of His Majesty,
those who marched to the battlefield therefore should endeavor to exalt
throughout the world the glories of the empire by fully realizing what the
country stands for and firmly upholding the moral tenants of the imperial army.
Yeah,
the imperial rescript to the Armed Forces is explicit while regulations and
manuals clearly defined conduct in combat and methods of training conditions in
the combat zone,
however,
tend to cons because soldiers to be swayed by immediate events and become
forgetful of their duty.
Indeed they should be wary
indeed.
They should be wary.
They're less,
they run counter to their duties as soldiers.
The purpose of this code lies and providing concrete rules of conduct in the
light of past experience so that those in the zone of combat may holy abide by
the imperial rescript to enhance the moral virtues of the imperial army.
So hey,
combat is going to be tough and you may forget your morals that they're talking
about moral virtues.
And so we're saying,
hey,
combat is going to be hard.
It's going to be chaotic,
and when you get in that tough situation,
you may forget your morals until this guide right here is going to help you keep
you on track.
That's what it's going to do.
That's the idea here.
Chapter one,
the empire Japan is the cocoa coop,
which means the empire,
the 10 which is the emperor of Japan,
rules over it everlastingly in a line unbroken through the ages as the successor
in the high and broad cause established by the imperial ancestor at the time of
the founding of the empire.
Imperial Benevolence is extended to all without favor,
while the imperial virtues enlighten the world,
okay,
the people to handing down from traditions of loyalty,
filial piety and F and valor from generation to generation and enhancing their
by their moral peculiar to the empire have assisted the throne,
a perfect national unity under the throne,
which has brought about the present national prosperity.
So they they,
they go that this,
this goes back to like a racial thing,
right?
Hey,
this,
this is an unbroken,
unbroken line of royalty for thousands of years and,
and that's why we're here and they've been so benevolent.
That's why we're living a good life right now.
Soldiers on the field should seek to achieve with unshakeable determination,
their mission of depen,
of defending the empire by laying to heart the essential character of the
national policy,
the army under command of the emperor assist in furthering the imperial fortunes
by enhancing the glories of the empire through the embodiment of the lofty
spirit of valor.
Okay.
This spirit is the basic factor in realizing universal peace.
Hey,
we're,
we're fighting for peace over here.
That's what we're doing for does this spirit of justice combined with valor and
of valor tempered by Van Benevolence in conformity with the imperial wishes.
So this is all good,
right?
That's where we're at.
This is all good.
This is a benevolent leader.
You've got the,
the,
the spirit of the army is actually just the reflection,
the arm of this benevolence that's going to go out and bring the spirit of peace
to the world valor.
But then we get into it a little bit.
Valid requires strictness.
While benevolence must be universal,
should there be an enemy who dares opposed the imperial army?
The army must resolutely resort to force of arms and deal him a crushing blow.
We took a little one 80 heritage way.
Hey,
we're all about getting our piece on,
but if you oppose,
if you dare to oppose the imperial army,
you're gonna get a crushing blow.
That's how we're rolling.
However,
even though force may compel the enemy sub to submit,
should a lapse of virtue should elapse in virtue occur by the striking of those
who do not resist or by failure to show kindness to those who surrender.
It cannot be said that such an army is perfect.
So there we got,
we got,
we're going to take care of the people that if you surrender your good,
if you don't resist,
you won't be harmed.
Right?
So we're like a benevolent army.
If you stand up to us,
we're going to crush you.
But if not,
it's cool.
Yeah,
we're gonna.
We're gonna take care of you.
Here's modest in its strength on Austin.
[inaudible] in its kindness.
The imperial army becomes an object of admiration when it quietly displays it's
valor and benevolence.
So here we are.
You know what I'm saying here?
You gotta be humble.
I say that all the time.
Gotta be humble.
That's what they're saying.
You got to be modest.
You gotta you got quietly display your strength,
right?
Sure.
Just be modest.
Yeah,
we agree with that.
The mission of the imperial army lies in making the imperial virtues,
the objects of universal admiration through the exercise of justice,
tempered with mercy.
Obviously the folks Nan King did not get this message
discipline,
and actually they truly didn't because if this didn't,
this wasn't released when the rape of Nanking took place.
This hadn't come out yet,
so they,
they truly did not get the memo of this correct.
At that time.
Discipline,
the essence of discipline in the imperial army lies in the lofty spirit of
complete obedience to His Majesty.
There you go.
The essence of discipline in the imperial army lies in the lofty spirit of
complete obedience to His Majesty.
High and low must have deeply engraved in their minds.
The solemn knee of the right of command.
Those above crew should exercise the right in all seriousness.
While those below should obey the commands in utmost sincerity.
Essential the victory and requisite for maintaining peace is the condition we're
in the entire army United in the bonds of absolute loyalty moves as one in
response to a command,
so we're,
this is where we're getting into it.
You know,
even the,
even the in the u s military,
you got to obey the lawful orders of the people appointed above you the lawful
orders.
That's the oath that you swear is that you'll obey the lawful orders.
It doesn't just say,
oh,
bay,
especially on the battlefield is the utmost observance of the spirit of
obedience necessary.
The spirit of the soldier is best exemplified by those who silently do their
duty joyfully braving death in obedience to a command given at a time when they
are undergoing undergoing great hardships.
There's no more important time that you need to obey.
Then on the battlefield,
next section,
unity.
The army looks up in all to his majesty as it's August head.
Yeah.
It will be United in compliance with the imperial will as one in spirit and in
body and in single hearted loyalty
and keeping with the basic principles of command and army unit should form a
solid yet genial group with its commander as its center.
It is essential that each man high and low dutifully observing his place should
be determined always to sacrifice himself for the hole in accordance with the
intentions of the commander,
by repurposing every confidence in his comrades and without giving even the
slightest thought to personal interest and to life or death.
So,
Hey,
I'm a firm believer.
In fact,
I think that's what makes a good player is someone that puts the team above
themselves,
no doubt about it.
That's also what makes a good leader,
someone that puts the team's mission and the people on the team above
themselves.
That's,
I agree with that.
Yeah.
I guess we're going a little next level here,
maybe a little bit.
Yeah.
You,
you gotta beat.
See there's a,
here's the difference.
I think it's in this word determined always to sacrifice for yourself for the
hole that's going to the next level,
right?
It's not like,
Hey,
I'm putting the team first.
It's like my goal is to sacrifice myself for the team.
That's where I'm heading.
That's what I'm trying to make happen.
That's a little different.
It's the little next level
cooperation.
Next section.
Cooperation of soldiers not only should be United in mind in carrying out their
tasks,
but should also display the spirit of cooperation by forgetting themselves for
the sake of victory.
Every unit should carry out its mission with responsibility upholding its honor,
placing confidence in others and assisting one another,
volunteering to face hardships,
exerting all its strength and cooperation and fighting valiantly to achieve its
objective.
Teamwork.
That's what we're saying.
We're talking about teamwork.
We are going a little next level here because we're talking about forgetting
yourselves for the sake of victory.
That's a,
that's a little next level.
Volunteering to face hardships while everyone does that in the military exerting
strengthen cooperation.
Yes.
Everyone does that in the military fighting valiantly to achieve its objective.
Everyone does that in the military,
but
for getting yourself for the sake of victory,
that I,
that's again,
this is like,
Hey,
I'm putting the team and the mission above me.
I get that we're not going to forget ourselves though,
right?
We're not just,
we're not just saying,
okay,
I don't exist.
We're not giving up our personal spirit for the collective spirit.
We're not doing that.
Well,
let me rephrase that.
We're not doing that in America.
That's not what we're doing.
We joined together the collective spirit,
but we're not given up ours.
Next section.
Aggressiveness
can't argue with aggressiveness.
Aggressiveness should constantly prevail in combat,
which must be carried out with bravery and determination when attacking,
be determined and positive.
Always taking the initiative,
fighting vigorously and stubbornly vowing not to cease until the enemy is
crushed.
I've got no issues with that
in defense.
Always retain the spirit of attack and always maintain freedom of action.
Never give up a position but rather die
in pursuit.
Be Thorough and inexhaustible.
Yeah,
so,
Yep.
Never give up position.
It's better to die.
And I think we talked about,
but we definitely talked about that on the podcast.
Like when is it intelligent to make a tactical retreat?
There are times without question and there's been times throughout history where
tactical retreats giving up positions has caused victory.
The imperial Japanese army is not talking about that.
They're talking about it's better to die.
Okay.
Continuing on act boldly,
intent upon victory,
be fearless and comm.
Meeting the situation courageously undergoing hardships with indomitable
perseverance so as to overcome all obstacles.
Okay,
I'm good with that.
Right?
That's what you gotta do in dominal.
Perseverance,
overcome all obstacles.
Good.
The next section,
conviction to win.
Faith.
His strength,
he who has faith in combat is always the victor.
The conviction to win grows from constant and rigorous training to develop the
strength to conquer the enemy by every possible effort and by improving every
moment,
no issues with that.
Get better.
Yeah.
Train hard,
rigorous con.
Rigorous training is going to definitely get to get you ready for Tufts
situations.
Got To have faith in what you're doing.
For sure.
The destiny of the Empire rests upon victory or defeat in battle.
It's a heavy weight to bear.
Do not give up under any circumstances.
Keeping in your mind your responsibility to keep untarnished the glorious
history of the imperial army with its tradition of invincibility.
Yeah,
that one's a stretch or taking a stretch now because I promise you that no man
and no army is invincible.
So we're getting a little stretch.
They're going a little too deep.
Next section,
chapter two,
and part one is called piety.
The gods look upon us from above.
Okay.
Be Worthy of divine protection by being pure in heart.
Just inaction,
profound and sincere in your piety.
Constantly mindful of the loyalty you,
oh the emperor,
end of duty to your parents.
So we're talking.
That's the first most important thing is your devotion to the emperor.
Okay?
That's,
that's,
that's the most important thing that we're talking about and the gods look upon
you from,
from above.
The gods are related to the emperor.
Okay.
The,
the next section is filial piety.
So now we're talking about reverence of our parents,
loyalty and filial piety as one form the law from form the essence of our
national morality.
Okay.
A loyal subject is always a dutiful son
endeavored to manifest the best traditions of our forefathers by bearing in mind
the wishes of your parents,
thereby fulfilling the sacred duty of a loyal subject on the battlefield.
Hey,
respect your parents.
I can get behind that.
Nothing wrong with that.
Try and be a good kid,
but sure.
No objections,
solutes and manners.
The solute is the expression of a sincere feeling of obedience
and is also a symbol of unity between those above and those below.
Solutes must be strictly executed on the field.
If a soldier is filled with a sense of decorum and strict in practicing good
manners,
it shows that he is a strong warrior.
To me,
this is weird.
It's just weird cause salutes.
You know,
salutes are a a definitely a time honored military tradition throughout the
world
and in the u s military,
you don't salute a lot in the field for sure.
In the seal teams you did.
Don't salute.
I mean very rarely,
there's not a lot of sweating going on basically because you're not walking
around when uniform all the time.
So there's not a lot of saluting going on.
But yeah,
so there's a lot of different ways to show respect and saluting is sort of the
most visible I guess way.
But it just,
it just kind of interesting to me that they're so into it.
Let me put it to this way.
This,
this is,
um,
you know,
when you see like a military movie,
which I'm sure you've seen some.
Yes sir.
When you see like the new guy officer,
right?
And he says,
Hey,
you better give me a solute sergeant.
Right?
Yeah.
And everyone knows that that guy's not a good leader immediately.
Right.
Cause you don't get all freaked out because someone doesn't salute you the way
they showed.
Sure.
So,
so now we have the whole military is acting like that.
The whole Japanese military is like,
hey,
you better salute.
That to me is a little bit,
and I get it right.
It's the,
it's the military tradition.
It is.
It's not a show of a BD as far as I'm concerned.
It's a respectful thing.
Like,
Hey,
you know,
their yard,
you're,
you're a senior officer or whatever.
Boom.
You get,
you crack
this salute.
It's all good.
Isn't it?
Like a symbol
of like just extreme discipline,
like know your place,
like know your role,
know your place.
Uh,
it does I guess signify that,
but really it's just about respect as far as I'm concerned.
You know,
boom.
You see someone that's senior to you,
boom,
you crack a salute,
I'll good.
Right.
But let's say like the kind of the functional use,
um,
of that respect is like,
you know,
I'm gonna come,
I'm gonna,
you know,
appear before you kind of thing.
And it's basically recognizing,
Hey,
I'm beneath you.
You're above me.
You know,
this is how we're functioning together right now.
There's my,
you know,
affirm,
what do you call,
like a conservation.
Conservation,
yeah,
yeah.
There is,
there is a that's there and it's,
and it's a way,
to me,
it's all about tradition and respect more than anything else.
Yeah.
You know,
um,
that's what it is.
It's about tradition and respect.
You,
you know,
you see someone that's senior,
an officer,
if you're an enlisted guy,
used to be all the officer's boom,
get them up.
That's the way it is,
but it's,
to me,
it's not like this crazy thing.
Like I never yelled at anyone for not saluting me.
Right.
Yeah.
You know,
and you probably couldn't find a lot of seals that would,
that have done that.
Uh,
now could you say that,
oh,
this there's,
you know,
you could see some kid that's being legitimately trying to be disrespectful,
right?
Yeah.
And maybe that person could get tightened up.
But yeah,
like on a few good men remember when he's like,
hey,
whatever happened to saluting an officer when he leaves the room and then the
guy puts his hands in his pocket.
Oh.
Dassey who,
who,
who puts their hand in the pocket?
His name was downy or doc Dawson.
Dawson.
Yeah.
It,
and who is he doing that to?
Tom Cruise.
Oh,
Dang.
Tom Cruise wasn't getting the respect,
so there you go.
Yeah.
There you go.
Good.
Good example.
Yeah,
but see what I'm saying?
No.
Um,
it's like,
but what does that respect kind of,
kind of reflecting the overall functionally,
it does seem like that.
It's like,
okay,
no knowing your place.
I'm here to kind of recognize that,
you know,
just in this small detailed way that that apparently will be unnecessary in
certain scenarios.
Yeah.
And I guess,
I guess what you're actually talking about is just good order and discipline.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's the way it is.
You know,
we just,
we just have this tradition,
this is,
you know,
this is what's happening.
Same thing with like polished shoes or,
or you know,
your uniform being squared is good order and discipline.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
Right.
So it's like there's no questions,
there's no wiggle room or whatever.
Like we're here to do the job like from a to Z and I'm just saying,
if you're freaking out about solutes than,
than you probably need to look at some other stuff that's going on around you.
You might be freaking out about the wrong thing is all I'm saying.
And
if you're good,
like if you're a good officer,
it's not like people are trying to avoid saluting you.
Yeah.
They're,
they're down there like,
you know,
hey,
here's a salute.
Let's do it.
All right.
Getting back to the book.
The way of comrades in arms,
comrades in arms that United in life and death for the imperial cause should
display full mutual trust should always endeavor to improve each other,
assist each other in distress and restrain each other against excesses in order
that they may joint fully fulfill their duties as soldiers.
It's all solid.
Hey,
we're going to trust each other.
We're in a worked always to improve each other.
We're going to help each other if we got a problem.
These are all fine.
All good to go.
Initiative.
Next.
Next section.
Initiative in exemplary conduct.
This is interesting because we're not just talking about an initiative because
initiative is good.
We want people to have initiative.
This initiative in exemplary conduct.
Leaders should be zealous in giving a worthy example in everything.
If there is disorder above those below will be unruly.
Action is prized on the field.
Leaders should provide an example by acting more courageously than others.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Good.
I mean,
can't,
can't really argue with those.
You got to have discipline.
You got to have order.
You got to set the example.
Can't,
can't argue with those next responsibility.
Duty is sacred.
No
one's responsibility is extremely heavy.
Each and every task must be performed with the utmost care until all a veal
available means are exhausted.
Those who have a strong sense of responsibility,
our bravest,
okay.
Of the brave on the field.
Yeah.
Okay.
Doody sacred.
You got responsible.
You gotta be responsible.
You got to take care with doing your thing.
Can't really argue with that one.
Next one.
View of life and death from the lofty spirit of self sacrificing service to the
state must prevail in life and in death.
Do your duty with heart and soul regardless of life or death.
After exerting all your powers,
spiritually and physically,
calmly faced death,
rejoicing in the hope of living in the eternal cause for which you serve.
You see little kamikaze activity creeping in right there.
Okay.
Honor.
Next section.
Strong are those who have a keen sense of honor.
Meet the expectations of your family and home community by making effort upon
effort.
Always mindful of the honor of your name.
If alive,
do not suffer the disgrace of becoming a prisoner.
Yeah.
Being deaf.
Do not leave behind a name soiled by misdeeds.
No surrender.
I was reading some,
and I forget the the facts off the top of my head,
but the number of the number of Japanese
military that were taken prisoner was like this tiny number.
It was like,
I don't know,
30 40 50,000 something like that.
And I say it's a tiny number when you compare it to the amount of Germans and
[inaudible],
there was millions of Germans that were,
you know,
taken prisoner at one point or another.
And again,
don't quote me on the number,
but it's,
the disparity is huge and this is why they were not going to be taken prisoner.
Okay,
next.
Simplicity and fortitude.
Hey,
of combat.
Keep things simple.
Fortitude.
Yes,
you got to have fortitude.
Here we go.
Let simplicity guide your daily life on the battlefield.
Promote habits of fortitude and a high morale.
Can't argue with that.
Life on the field must be playing.
Consider privation,
your daily lot in endeavor to be thrifty,
luxury,
saps valor.
Oh,
I like that.
There you go.
Luxury saps valor.
Theo Vaughn,
are you listening?
Luxury can have those luxury days too often.
This is this idea of simplicity of course important.
And even,
you know,
I talk about simplicity from a,
from a,
from a communications viewpoint and from a planning viewpoint.
But in life simplicity is a very positive thing.
You know,
you've got the,
the modern day minimalist movement.
Are you familiar with that?
Yes.
Where you don't own anything.
Mm hmm.
Or as little as you can.
Yeah.
Though the cool,
one of the coolest things about going on deployment in the day aims Burger,
one of the coolest things about it is you be,
everyone's a minimalist.
It's just you go on deployment,
you have like whatever,
five bags in in the bags,
you have three,
you know,
three pairs of pants,
two pairs of boots for tee shirts,
got your weapon,
got your body armor
like you're,
it's so awesome.
And it feels really good when you're able to get away from all that stuff that
you got piling up back in your big house with the big closets and you got all
that stuff in there and all that stuff weighs down on you.
So when you get to do,
you know Tony BTF where he used to joke about,
you know,
when you out,
like,
you know you got problems going on and meal at home and everyone's just like
bothering you and he's like,
get on a,
you just get on a c one 30 boom,
everything's fine.
And I agree with that.
You would get that feeling of everything's fine.
You're guest,
hey,
there's nothing.
All you have to worry about as the bad guys.
Right,
right.
It's very easy.
It's very focused.
You don't have all this other stuff going on and you don't have all this other
literal stuff.
You just got what you need.
You don't break if you don't bring it,
if you don't need it,
you don't bring it because you want this other stuff.
Yeah,
yeah.
Right.
So you,
you keep it,
keep it simple is what you keep it.
And that's what they're saying here.
And you know,
of course,
I doubt,
I doubt that the emperor was living,
you know,
a simple life of privation in the palace,
right?
No.
But if we can convince all the people,
if we can convince everyone that they should just be living like in the dirt,
cool.
More from me.
So there's a little bit of that going on.
Trying to keep the people with the positive mindset even though they don't have
anything telling them that you don't want anything cause it's going to SAP your
valor.
You want to live it lead,
right?
Yeah.
Luxury saps valor.
True statement though.
True statement,
right?
What happens to rock and roll bands
there at valor gets up to me.
No,
they come out with a good album,
right?
Good hard album.
And everyone goes,
yes,
that's,
that's uh,
that's it.
Kick ass album.
And then the next thing you know,
they're living a life of luxury and their music gets soft and weak.
Yeah.
Maybe it's saps their valor saps their grit.
Next up.
Integrity.
Integrity is the foundation of the spirit of the warrior.
How can a man who cannot conquer his worldly desires devote his life to the
country,
be austere in your daily behavior?
Dealer deal with matters justly so that you will not be ashamed of your conduct
in the sight of God or man.
Okay,
Hey,
cool,
right act,
you know,
keep control over your desires.
Got It.
Let that sounds like a good idea.
You know,
act in such a way that your debt,
people,
you know,
this goes back to the,
Hey,
imagine you're being at someone's video,
you at all times,
and then how do you really want to act the way?
If everyone was watching you all the time,
how would you act?
You want to make the right decisions so that you can stand up before other man
or God and be like,
Yep,
I'm,
my actions were fine.
Yeah,
so that's what,
that's what this is saying.
Can we argue against that?
Not really.
What was interesting is you read some of those kamikaze letters.
A lot of them specifically say
there was no,
I have no,
I have no woman in my life.
They specifically say that like I've read a bunch of those letters.
I don't know how many but a lot.
And there's a decent percentage,
I don't know,
maybe 10% which is a lot when you think about it.
But a lot of the letters in them who knows them,
the actual percentage.
But if you read some of those letters,
you'll see,
you'll see these young 18 1920 years olds bragging to their parents.
I have no female in my life.
Oh they say and then a positive story,
Paul,
the most positive possible way that I have.
No.
They'll say,
you know,
I have no need for money or women.
They say these things.
So they're actually telling their parents like I all I have is you.
Right.
They're more looking to honor their parents than they are looking to have a
girlfriend.
Yeah.
Which to me is,
is really jacked up.
You know,
when you're 18 years old,
you have a girlfriend.
Sure.
Am I wrong?
You know,
to each their own,
I guess,
Bruh.
Come on.
You're 18 years old.
An 18 year old needs a girlfriend.
Yeah.
No,
not if he's like committed to the cause.
You know,
I always felt that like,
especially at 18 if you're committed to like,
I don't know if it well again to each their own for sure.
But it is not uncommon for an 18 year old dedicated to,
uh,
what's the cause,
color,
whatever,
in whatever situations you need to get jammed up because they got some,
oh no,
that's true.
I'm not saying the girlfriend's won't won't jam you up.
Oh yeah,
they will.
So especially when you're 17,
16,
18,
14,
13,
1920,
24,
it evens out at about 30.
Let's fix,
that's where you get a grip.
That's where you get a grip probably because of yourself to be honest with you.
But what's 100% as yourself?
That's not the girl.
Yeah,
it's you,
but yes.
So the,
you know,
like,
uh,
I don't know.
He 18.
What did he do at 18 military?
I would imagine,
uh,
I know in football it was like that.
The girlfriend,
you know,
it's like getting in.
Okay.
But no girls whatsoever.
Are you talking like,
yeah.
Oh yeah.
Just an ins from girls.
I'm not saying actual ads.
Take it into the next level.
Echo Charles.
No,
but I am saying if you're trying to demonstrate or illustrate the your loyalty
to parents,
the cause,
whatever.
Yes.
You say like,
Bruh,
I don't even,
girls don't even like,
you know,
waiver,
my dedication to the cause,
you know,
I get that.
That's what this is saying.
Yes.
I'm just saying,
I don't think I necessarily agree with the 19 1820 year old male human having no
female interaction.
Yeah.
To me that just sounds like not the best idea.
Well let's put it this way.
I agree with you,
but I agree with this because I feel like that's just what they're saying.
No,
definitely.
I agree with you.
Yeah,
It's,
and I think what hit me weird was the,
the kamikaze pilots that are just like so happy that they don't have a
girlfriend.
I'm thinking,
are you really that happy that you don't have a girlfriend?
And if you are that happy that you don't have a girlfriend,
they kept you in lockdown.
Right?
They kept you in a serious lockdown.
Yes.
Because do you remember?
I mean,
when you're a boy,
when you're 10 years old,
when you're 11 years old,
12 years old,
like you already looking at girls like,
oh,
I want to hang out with that,
that thing right over there,
that girl,
I want to go like talk to that.
Right.
Talk to that thing.
You know what I'm saying?
Like it's a,
I know instinct.
Yes.
That is fully there as,
as a dude.
Right?
But at the most cases,
at that point,
I would argue that in most cases you're not consciously thinking of a
meaningful,
productive relationship necessarily.
You just have a sort of a feeling in a sort of like attraction or draw towards
this thing and that attraction and draw towards this thing.
Yeah.
We'll get in the way.
Or at the very least come right.
I get you out.
I'm saying I hear you.
Yes you gotta be.
And definitely if you're 17 years old,
you gotta be careful that the girls don't pull you off track.
Yeah.
And by the way,
I'm saying this in one direction,
same thing,
opposite direction.
I guess I should've said that,
but wouldn't,
you know,
girls will get pulled off track by,
by boys.
Yes.
You know,
so I guess what we're talking about is getting the relationship going.
Yeah.
Okay.
I agree with you.
If you are fully committed to the cause,
one thing that could fall away from your commitment would be,
look,
I'm not even,
I don't care about girls.
That's where I'm at.
Okay.
I get you.
I'll give it to you.
Actually,
you kind of have to because you were like that.
Even when you said when you were overseas,
you didn't like,
you know,
you didn't want to think about your family,
you to where you want to do.
Right.
So what would he even made it better technically in this specific way is to not
even have a family,
not even to have a girlfriend,
not even the ultimate commitment.
Exactly.
Right.
So,
yeah.
So that's what they're going to say,
you know?
Yeah.
No,
that's,
that's the ultimate commitment.
You are correct.
I don't agree with it though.
Well,
ironically,
I don't agree with it.
If you're just,
well,
you,
so you see their point.
Yes,
sir.
And I see their point and that's why I kind of lived that way when I was
overseas.
Hey,
I don't want to look at pictures of my wife and kids while I'm here.
I want to focus on the mission at hand.
But that's a lot different than coming home and and saying,
oh,
I don't wanna.
I don't want to have any,
a female in my life.
Yeah.
It's a lot different.
Or if
you're a female saying,
look,
I don't,
I know what's going to be focused on,
I guess.
I guess that happens,
you know,
on the other way to,
yeah.
Fully you a female that's committed to her career,
so she doesn't want to have kids.
She doesn't want to get married because she's focused on the career.
Yeah.
Which is actually cool,
but it is an extreme way to way to get down.
All right.
Well,
I don't believe there's any conduct that you need to be ashamed of if you have a
girlfriend is what I'm saying.
There you go.
All right.
Chapter three,
counsel,
concerning field service,
a moments negligence may result in an unexpected catastrophe.
Be Constantly on your guard.
Do not despise your enemy or the natives,
not be negligent after a small success.
Okay,
let's just go through somebody.
so a moment's negligence negligence may result in an unexpected catastrophe.
That's a great point.
Pay Attention.
Be Constantly on your guard.
Great Point.
Pay Attention.
Do not despise your enemies or the natives.
Great Point,
right?
We're going to go fight with honor and we're not going to abuse the natives.
Do not be negligent after a small success.
Great Point.
That's when you're going to get arrogant and your ego gets out of control and
you get caught.
No,
that carelessness brings disaster.
Great Point.
So there you go.
That's just opening up.
There's,
here's how we roll.
I wonder if this document was written like as a reaction to Nan King I if they
had a little like,
oh we,
we let that happen,
we got to tighten up.
I wonder if they actually did that.
The U s military does that kind of thing.
Like something will go,
hey,
the prisoner abuse happened in,
in Abu Ghraib.
They made all kinds of rules and regulations about what you do with prisoners
after that.
Yeah.
I wonder if this is the same kind of thing.
They tried to tighten them up.
Century duty is important upon the century.
Rest of the safety of an army.
He also represents the discipline of an army.
Those on century duty must devote their entire person to the task,
which must be sternly carried out.
Accord the century,
high respect.
Cool gotta be on guard.
Next,
ideological warfare is an important phase in modern conflict.
Destroy Propaganda and fabrications of the enemy by your unshakable faith in the
cause for which the empire stance and endeavor to spread Codo which again,
that's the spirit of the empire.
So
they're telling you to watch out for the enemy propaganda and how you overcome
it is by having unshakable faith.
Next up.
Rumors arise from a lack of confidence.
Do not be misled,
not be agitated by them.
Firmly believe in the strength of the Imperial Army and deeply trust your
superiors.
Hmm.
Deeply trust your superiors.
There is no be wise on the end of that.
And yeah,
I notice like the American manual said,
said,
trust your spirits but be wise.
Also rumors arise from a lack of confidence.
I disagree with that.
I think rumors are arise from lack of knowledge and lack of hearing the truth
because the way you overcome rumors is to tell people the truth.
That's how you stop rumors.
Tell people the truth.
Ah,
not number six,
be mindful to protect enemy property and resources,
requisitions,
seizures and destruction of goods and similar actions must be executed in
keeping with the regulations and always under the orders of your commanding
officer.
This is incredible there literally saying,
Hey,
you know when you,
when you defeat someone,
you've got enemy property.
You need to treat it well.
You can't seize it.
You can't destroy it.
There you go.
This is like guidance.
Mm
seven be gentle
and protect innocent inhabitants in the spirit of benevolence,
in accordance with the true ideal of the imperial army.
Like I said,
maybe this is a reaction to what happened in Nan king cause there was no being
gentle and no protecting the innocent there who was a complete opposite.
Number eight those on the field must not indulge in wine and women or allow
desire to be cloud their consciences thereby damaging the prestige of the
imperial army and causing the dissipation of a body dedicated to service.
So that one is written for Echo Charles.
Yeah.
No.
Why no women does it just going to get,
it's going to jam you up.
They will
concur.
Okay.
They should exercise self control lest they per smirch the pure character of
warriors.
Nine control your anger.
Good to go and suppress your grudges.
The ancients said,
consider anger your enemy.
A moments of violence often leaves because for a long regret it's great advice.
Control your anger,
control of your emotions,
the severity of military laws designed to specialty to uphold the good name of
soldiers and to preserve the dignity of the imperial army.
Always remember the oath that you made and the deep emotion that you felt when
you left home.
Yeah,
call to mind how your parents,
your wife and your children think of you and avoid exposing yourself to crime.
Okay,
good guidance.
Okay.
Two achievements.
Achievements of soldiers in service.
Foster the tradition of respecting Marshall attainments,
cultivate and train the warriors of virtues and arts.
Remember that,
do not allow yourself to become board is the saying of an ancient general.
So,
Hey,
look,
we're telling people to train,
train warrior arts,
train the virtues of the warriors.
This is all good stuff.
And,
and remembered that.
Two D don't allow yourself to become bored.
When's the last time you were bored?
I a time member?
Yes.
Yeah.
I'm not really one getting bored over here on my side either.
Next,
do not allow yourself to worry about the fate of those at home in the event of
your death,
but devote yourself wholly to service.
Be always ready to meet death without regret.
By settling your affairs beforehand,
a soldier is always prepared to expose his corpse on the battlefield.
Yeah.
Let his family know that at times,
even his ashes may not reach them.
So there's,
you know,
again,
there's some kamikaze attitudes sneaking in there that you,
you may have to lay it all down next to the,
there is nothing more to be regretted than to fall victim to a disease on the
field.
Be particularly mindful of your health so that you may not be unable to serve
because of excesses.
So,
so you've got to keep track of your health.
Don't get sick.
Lay to heart.
The saying of an ancient warrior.
My sword is my soul,
my horses,
my fortune.
Always take care of your arms and supplies and give humane attention to animals
on the field.
Solid.
Okay.
Take care of your gear and your gear to take care of you.
Have you ever heard that before?
Yes.
From me.
Okay Sir.
That's a good one.
Yeah.
Seems good.
It's a true one.
Seems true.
Yeah.
Virtue in the battlezone is the source of strength in combat.
Always consider the interests of other units and do not monopolize billets and
materials.
Remember the saying,
a bird taking flight does not muddy the water.
Yeah.
Let the good reputation of the valorous imperial army long remain the cause of
fond recollections in an alien land.
So there you go.
They're telling everyone to,
you know,
have it be virtuous in the,
in the combat zone.
Bird in flight does not muddy the water.
I think it just means as you elevate,
then you're not,
you know,
you don't need to get mad because it's not muddying the water.
It's good.
You're moving forward.
Yeah.
Could be wrong.
Very obscure.
A bird taking flight does not muddy the water.
Let the good reputation
of the valorous imperial army long remain the cause of recollections and alien.
The land.
Yeah.
I think that's what it means.
Like,
Hey,
this is where elevated,
where,
hey,
we're in this land.
We're here,
we invaded,
but we're not going to muddy the water.
We're,
we're in flight.
Next.
Do not boast of one one's achievements,
but give others credit.
But to give others credit is one of the most respected traditions among
warriors.
Hmm.
This is straight out of extreme ownership.
Straight out of the dichotomy of leadership.
No,
you don't.
You don't boast of achievements.
You give your credit to your team.
Do not begrudge others their promotion or cherish resentment because your
services are not recognized,
but instead reflect upon your own shortcomings.
This is,
this is solid.
That's solid advice,
right?
Oh,
you got promoted.
I didn't.
I'm just going to get mad at you.
No.
Instead I should look at myself and say,
okay,
what did that go do that I didn't do?
What could I do better?
What am I shortcomings?
Yeah.
Next,
be honest.
Always consider exaggerations in lies dishonorable.
Cool.
Where,
where 100% on board with that always bear yourself as a member of a great
nation.
Treading the path of righteousness and seeking justice so that you may enhance
the prestige of the empire.
Totally positive date in the seal teams for a little while.
They were trying to,
it was,
uh,
it was something along the lines of I will not dishonor my team,
my unit,
my navy,
or my nation.
This is the same exact thing they've got written right there.
You know,
you wanna you wanna make the,
the empire look good.
You want to damage the,
the,
yeah.
Reputation.
Next.
Also do not show a lack of consideration for international courtesies.
Okay.
And finger about that.
Yeah.
Hey,
when you go to another country,
don't,
uh,
you know,
take in consideration there their customs and courtesies.
That's a good thing to do.
And the last one for this section,
should you receive the order to return home alive after briefing 10,000 deaths?
Think of those brave souls who will not return.
Yeah,
be determined to become an example to the people by being careful in word and
deed,
renewing your vows to serve the country.
Nothing wrong with that.
And then this is how this thing ends.
The conclusion,
the conclusion is above all the above originate from an n in the imperial
rescript
let them serve as a guide in putting into practice this battlefield morality.
So that all may be perfect in obeying the imperial commands,
soldiers and officers on the field,
lay heart later heart,
the import of the above by fully realizing the significance of real service to
the state in order that you may carry out your duty as soldiers,
thus responding to the boundless imperial benevolence.
Okay,
so like I said,
there's
parts of that document that you can't really argue with and it's a powerful
document.
It's a powerful code.
And that document
obviously helped guide the actions of
yeah.
Of the,
of the military in Japan and of the nation of Japan.
Who were
highly committed to this cause.
Okay.
Completely committed to this cause.
Got One more letter from a kamikaze.
Okay.
Dear mother and father.
Now what has been decided that I will participate in a sorority as a member of
the kamikaze special attack core squadron.
I am deeply satisfied that nothing will surpass this as the long cherished
desire of a military man to die in attacking an enemy ship together with his
aircraft.
When I think of my 23 years of life,
I've not been able to repay anything for your kindness.
However,
with a smile,
please forgive me from the beginning I offered myself for the country.
Okay.
The war is plunging into an increasingly critical period,
but I believe
okay.
In victory for the empire,
I believe others will follow after me smiling.
I will make a body crashing attack against an enemy ship.
I am resolved that I will repay a tense,
a 10 thousandths of the emperor's kindness.
I have not been as thankful as today to be born a Japanese person.
Yeah,
I lie.
Humble subject.
Live not in vain.
Having seen both heaven and earth prosper in this glorious age of vine.
This is an old poem and it is my state of mind.
Yeah.
Please give regards to my teachers at elementary school,
junior high school and teachers.
Yeah.
In College,
all of the relatives and the villagers.
Finally,
I am praying for the welfare of everyone in the family.
Bravely.
I will fall knowing the way of Samurai
for the emperor who gave blessings,
naval ensign,
Schangiel Duh.
And at 1245 on April 6th,
1945 and [inaudible] took off from crew Shira airbase
and carried out his suicide attack off the coast of Okinawa.
Yeah.
And when you hear this code
and when you hear these letters,
you have to think to yourself
who could,
who could defeat
okay.
On the enemy.
That is,
that determined what,
what a warrior culture could have the values and the courage to contend with and
to actually defeat,
uh,
people possessed with such willingness to make sacrifices,
such a willingness to die for their cause.
That's what you have to ask yourself.
Yeah.
That's what I ask myself is what,
what people could oppose.
Yeah.
And fight against this,
this warrior breed.
And the answer to that question,
and this isn't,
this isn't a theoretical answer,
but it's it,
it's a factual answer.
The warrior culture that faced and defeated this fanatic society
was he United States of America,
and it was our own hardened to breed of warriors from the army,
Navy,
air force,
and Marines,
the American warrior culture.
Yeah.
The American warrior culture is what went from island to island and beachhead to
beachhead and pillbox box to pillbox fighting and sacrificing
not only with a willingness to die,
which they certainly had,
but with a stronger willingness
to live,
yeah.
To live and not to live a life of subservience and obedience,
but a life of something much more powerful than all of that.
A life of freedom
and that culture,
that American culture of individual freedom has proven out to be the most
powerful force in the world
and for us to be able to protect that freedom.
What we do is we voluntarily impose discipline on ourselves
and we have the things that this book talked about.
We have,
we have conviction to win,
we believe in loyalty.
And responsibility.
We live with honor and valor and we work together to protect each other,
but we don't do that because we're mandated to do that.
We do it so we can defend our way of life.
We make sacrifices to preserve our culture because our way of life offer
something,
something that is the apex of human existence,
freedom,
life,
liberty and the pursuit of happiness.
But that's why we fight
and that's why we win.
We don't fight for glory.
We don't fight for personal gain.
We don't fight to impose our will on to others,
but we fight for freedom,
freedom itself.
That is our ideal.
That is our standard
and we will never ever surrender that ideal.
The ideal of freedom.
Freedom is our code
and I think that's all I've got for
tonight.
Echo Charles.
Yeah,
it's good.
We are trying to maintain our freedom.
Yes.
In order to do that,
we all know that we have to,
you know,
impose some discipline on ourselves.
Yes sir.
That means putting in the work yes.
Means trying to get better.
Sure.
I know you've got some things that might help us as we head down that path.
Yeah,
very much so.
But the,
the imperial,
the emperor kind of seems like that's the part that kind of jammed everything
up.
Like this whole code,
like the whole,
what does this manual called perial.
Rescript yeah.
For soldiers and sailors.
Yeah.
It's,
it's like,
man,
this is all good.
This is all good.
And to except that one spot where they were like,
yeah,
the emperor is like a line of p kind of as if to say,
okay and,
but at the end of the day,
like you got to listen to this like one kid where as at the end of the day,
what we do is individual freedom.
You ain't for nobody else.
Yeah.
Like we were collectively protecting this freedom that we have and we do that
together.
But once we have that freedom,
it's not about,
for someone else,
it's for,
it's for the individual.
It's for life,
liberty and the pursuit of happiness.
That's what we're doing over here.
That's what the,
that's what Western culture is about.
Yeah.
And
you know,
the fact that you have all this code written and everything,
right.
You have these people raised the boost cheeto mindset and all that.
But like the marines are going onto the beach at Guadalcanal.
Yeah.
That's what's going to happen.
And,
and,
and going into a four to five island,
you're at a complete disadvantage.
Don't,
don't,
don't let anyone forget that.
Yeah.
When you're going against,
when you're on the office against a defensive position,
you are at a complete disadvantage.
That's the way it is.
Yeah.
And
so,
so this,
this warrior culture that sometimes we put up on a pedestal because it sounds
cool.
It sounds cool to be imperial rescripts sounds cool when you put this code out.
Right.
But what you,
what you just said is correct.
When that code is not based and not the foundation of it isn't freedom
doesn't turn out good.
Yeah.
And it's essentially like,
it sounds cool because you know how you,
it Kinda ties into it where you,
okay,
so does millennials' freedom,
we'll say,
right.
We'll start with that discipline.
Sounds cool.
Yep.
And equals freedom.
That whole thing sounds cool.
Whatever.
So this Bushido thing kind of just seems like just the discipline part.
So of course that part of it sounds cool,
but when you look at big picture,
you know how not cool that is like especially like to have to bow down to like
some group of people.
That's the way it is.
Family,
you know?
Yeah.
So you step back,
you look at that,
you're like,
man,
this isn't cool.
Actually.
This is like kind of bad.
Especially when you get,
um,
corruption for sure.
Which is kind of,
this is one of the,
I forget the same,
but it's like absolute power is absolute absolute power corrupts.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
So the men,
so you kind of consider that.
And that's a,
that's a big picture thing too,
cause he no one knows come out.
I mean,
I wasn't saying no one comes out of the gate corrupt,
but that's not true either.
But when you can have something like this where it's like,
hey,
the emperor there,
you know,
they're benevolent,
they're defined,
you know,
all this stuff or whatever.
And it's like,
yeah,
okay,
that sounds cool.
But man,
after a while,
big picture,
you're like,
God damn well you're not divine.
You're just a person.
And the whole absolute power corrupts absolutely is like,
that's a very high likelihood and all this stuff.
So given that that they can just say whatever they want,
they can be like,
hey,
I don't care.
18 year old kid out of high school or whatever,
Oh yeah,
we need,
we need to use you as a bullet.
That's really what they're doing.
Especially like the numbers,
the numbers are like,
Bro,
you killed one Japanese person for like every one point something other person
like enemy.
So it was like bow two bullets are worth more than you really in a way,
you know?
And some like person can just sort of make that determination with your whole
life Brown and oh man,
that doesn't sound good.
Yeah.
In this,
that's why this whole,
this whole thing,
this,
it just boils down to,
and it's such an overused word,
man.
It boils down to freedom.
That's what it boils down to.
Yeah.
Like when you are a man and you're from Iowa and you're in the marine corps and
you're going onto that beach,
your wheel as a free man
is stronger than the will of this guy over on the other side that is not truly
free.
Yeah.
And that,
that right there,
that's the,
that's the crazy thing about this is you can take this,
this entire warrior culture where these people are born and raised and taught
this and you seem,
uh,
you know,
there's,
there's training videos for the kamikaze,
but even just the,
just the militant life that these,
the militaristic life that they led.
And meanwhile you take someone that was a shoe cobbler and Boston and you take
another guy that was a farmer in Iowa and you take another guy that worked on
the railroad in California and you put them together in a foxhole and their will
to fight as free men.
He's stronger than someone that was raised since birth to be a warrior
freedom and the,
the individual human will to do what you want to do with your life as such is
the most powerful force.
And it gets left,
it gets left behind.
And if you leave it behind,
you might win for a little while,
but you're not going to win in the long run.
And that's the,
that's the force.
If you that to a personal level,
that's the force that you can use to drive discipline in your life because you
want you,
you don't impose discipline on yourself for,
for the sake of discipline.
Yeah.
That's going to be,
you can,
you can do that.
You can do that today.
You can do that tomorrow.
You can do that next week,
but you can't do that for two years,
three years.
You need,
it needs to be the foundation of the discipline needs to be the desire for
freedom.
Okay.
That's what it has to be rooted in.
At least that's for me.
For me,
that's what it's rooted in.
Yeah.
And like,
okay,
discipline for the sake of discipline.
That sounds cool.
Yeah.
Right.
Sounds awesome.
Dig into it a little bit,
right.
Not Be digging into it a little bit.
And what do you find?
It's gotta be disciplined for freedom
and it,
and it's,
it's functional on the battlefield
and
it's functional in your life.
Yeah.
You know,
it's the same thing with the same thing with the Nazis.
The Nazis were a Marshall,
a martial culture,
you know,
that's what they were,
but they were subservient to the fear.
And guess what happens when you take,
guess what happens when you take a kid from North Carolina
and you take another kid from Florida and you take another kid from Tennessee
and you take those kids,
they're not professional soldiers.
They're going to go to bootcamp.
They're going to get trained in whatever they're going to get trained in.
They're not ready.
They're not Hitler.
Youth raised to fight.
You ever seen little,
little Hitler youth training with weapons when they're 12 years old?
Like meanwhile this kid was in Tennessee working on a farm.
This other kid was in Brooklyn working in a pizza shop,
working in a restaurant,
whatever.
Hmm.
So you take these folks that are fighting for the fewer,
you put them up against someone that's a group of people that are fighting for
freedom
and freedom is going to win.
Thank you.
Are Right about,
yeah,
it's interesting.
Yeah.
Like the freedom to do Jujitsu by the way,
and the freedom to get any kind of,
gee you want,
but you're going to get the best gifts.
Almost qualified as a rough transition as well.
I'm just saying that's the first thing that came to mind at that point when you
said that.
Nonetheless.
Anyway,
we're on the path.
Yes.
Discipline.
The Path is the path of discipline that ends in not ends in,
but results in freedom.
Yeah.
So on this path,
many activities,
many things to do and to not do.
By the way,
you know what,
what you were talking about earlier with like the salute thing.
Look at that for a second.
Right?
If I'm a guy that's like,
has an attitude local,
not saluting anyone.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm not disciplining myself.
Well guess what?
The night I'm not gonna do anything in the military.
I'm going to get kicked out of the military.
Actually I'm going to lose the freedom to serve.
Yeah.
Whereas if you,
if you discipline yourself like,
Hey,
I'm going to show respect to the people that are above me,
the chain of command,
yeah,
I'm going to do a good job.
Yeah.
I'm going to discipline myself.
Guess what?
It's ridiculous.
This is going to sound so ridiculous.
For the most part.
I can pretty much do whatever I wanted to when I was in the military.
As crazy as that sounds,
as crazy as that sounds,
my bosses always gave me what I wanted my,
I could just kind of do,
do what I wanted to do.
It was crazy.
When I look back on it now and in my bosses would give me what I want and help
me and support me.
Why did they do that?
They didn't do it because I was manipulating what they did it because I was
working hard and supporting what they wanted to get done and it's like a
positive thing.
It's not negative at all.
It's like it was awesome.
But if you,
and if you have that attitude in life like,
Hey,
I'm gonna work hard.
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna Discipline Myself.
Yeah.
I'm going to submit in situations that require it.
I'm going to subordinate my ego in situations that require it now so that in the
long run I can get the freedom.
Okay.
So often people,
they don't want to,
they want the freedom.
Right now you have,
freedom isn't going to come right now.
Don't get it.
Yeah.
You have to work for it.
You have to fight for it.
You have to impose discipline on your life so that you can end up with it.
You have to work hard.
You know,
you have to work hard to get to a point when you get the freedom.
But if you don't work hard,
yeah.
Do you want to end up with it?
You just won't.
You'll always end up being a slave to,
to your paycheck.
You'll be a slave to your,
you're jacked up friends.
You'll be a slave to the manipulative partner you chose.
You know,
you,
you'll be a slave if you don't put discipline in your world,
be slave,
did drugs,
he'd be a slave to drugs.
You'd be a slave to alcoholic,
can be a slave to food.
You can be a slave to doctors.
Yeah.
You can be slave to all these things.
So
it's just,
you gotta think about freedom.
You've got to have that in the back of your mind,
but you can't,
you can't live your life thinking that it's going to be given to you.
Oh No.
It's not.
Freedom isn't free,
as they say,
is this,
freedom isn't free in a country.
And freedom certainly isn't free in your own personal life.
It's not free.
Oh No.
Yeah.
Like we,
and we talked about this early on where you're going to have to pay the price,
you know?
Yeah.
When,
you know,
pay now,
pay later,
whatever you say.
So the,
the whole pain now,
I think that's the way to go.
Paying now is definitely the way to go.
Yeah.
You always get a pay and it's a constant thing and that,
that parking kind of be intimidating,
you know,
where it's like,
like let's say,
you know,
Bill,
the real obvious ones like eating correctly and exercising,
right?
Like that's what's good about those as they,
the physical activities that have physical,
visible manifestations,
right.
If you eat like crap,
you're gonna feel like crap.
You're going to look like crap.
You're going to perform my crop.
Yeah.
If you are inactive,
are going to move like crap,
you're going to be sick.
So yeah,
those are real clear.
Yeah.
Examples.
So it's like so clear where you can be like,
okay,
I'm going to paint now,
right?
How am I going to pay now and what price am I going to pay now?
And that's with like,
yeah.
Not eating things that you're so physically compelled to you.
Um,
for the most part,
uh,
exercising,
which can be a pain literally.
And so,
you know,
no one,
most of the time you don't like want to exit.
Like that's not a natural thing,
I think to like,
I would say that's true.
I would say actually,
you're right.
I would say that you're right to the point where a normal human being is
genetically programmed.
If they can conserve energy,
then you want to conserve energy because otherwise if you didn't have that
instinct,
you waste all your energy as a caveman and you would die.
Right.
Because you'd starve to death.
So No,
I think we're genetically programmed to,
to lean towards less activity on energy conservation is what we're probably
genetically programmed to do.
Yeah,
yeah.
Genetic.
I'd get it if you're sitting in an office all day and the new moon,
okay,
we'd go for a run tonight.
Yeah,
of course.
He didn't sit in an office all day,
so,
you know,
so there's gotta be some instinct to do that as well.
But yeah.
But most of time to,
if you're going to go for a run or go lift or something like you're already
familiar with,
like the payoff of that,
you know,
no one,
I mean,
it's pretty rare.
Maybe if you want to go play,
play in the pool or something,
I guess.
But that's different.
Like no one's just genetically yearning to go.
Do metcon or something or run like a marathon or something like that.
Well,
that's why I kind of threw that out there a little bit because sometimes if you,
for me,
yeah,
like some of those are,
you know,
but,
but for real,
right.
Let's say you,
let's say you couldn't work out for two days.
Do you have like a little like thing that smacking would get?
They're jerks too.
Oh yeah.
Big Time.
But then so there's,
right,
but that's for someone who are you connecting that to off.
Okay,
I got it.
And it's like,
and it through,
and we talked about this too,
where that's kind of a good [inaudible] don't you just like to just go get some
though?
Yes.
Only for the payoff.
So I'm not as,
I like to get some just to get signed.
No,
because you're you,
and that's like a lousy,
like it was gonna say that that's like one of the benefits of work and this
dude,
we're just talking about working out.
But this goes for kind of everything where if you familiarize yourself over the
years of the payoff,
like your body kind of accommodates that.
Make your buddies.
Like if you don't,
you get endorphins and you get addicted to it.
Yeah.
And that becomes Holly.
That'd becomes how you work.
So,
but let's say like,
okay,
let's say I'm,
I don't know,
35 years old will say,
I've never really worked out ever.
Right.
It just live a normal life for what I had just never really worked out in every
like lifted weights,
never went for runs.
You'll have less of a desire than someone that's been worried about their whole
life.
Trey,
go workout for the first time.
A hard one.
Do want to Jockos workouts.
And you'd be like,
I don't want to do this.
You're going to be thinking about while you're doing it and the next day when
you're all so you can be late.
But I don't want to do that ever again actually.
So it's different.
But if you're you or someone who's like,
you know an athlete all their life or something like that.
Someone who who reap the benefits,
they know they're familiar with with the payoff.
Yes.
When you don't work out for one day,
two days,
well you know however many days.
Yeah,
you're going to be like,
your body is going to be like,
hey,
like we need that workout now kind of thing.
For short term,
short term payoff,
we need that workout.
So the,
again,
the benefit of getting into working on a regular basis,
you get short term and longterm path
and that's what our path is by the way.
Anyway,
same thing for Jujitsu.
It's a big one.
If you take off,
do you did like you've been out of Jujitsu for a little bit cause you're,
you're hurting right now eating it.
Yeah man.
Yeah.
You're,
I just walked out to the gym.
I kind of looked at maths.
I got all excited.
Right.
Yeah.
You should be back.
I'll be back in a week.
All right.
Back on there.
Well no,
sorry,
two weeks.
I'll be back on the maths of pop.
Just this boom.
There it is.
So while you're doing,
just if you haven't started,
you too,
if you haven't like,
cause you know there's a number of people who are like,
Hey,
I hear all the things I'm on the fence.
You know,
they just haven't made the plunge.
They haven't taken the step to even just try it.
Because usually places you go,
they'll give you it's free.
Try for free.
Free.
Yeah.
That's,
which tells you that you did see is good because they don't say,
hey,
try this for free.
They don't try and get your money.
Oh yeah.
Come on in.
It's like giving away free crack at the school yard,
but it's the good kind know reacts.
It's cracked.
That makes you like a better human being.
That's basically what Jujitsu is.
Yes.
It's like,
uh,
it's like,
an addictive drug that makes you better,
stronger,
smarter,
faster,
more calm,
more patient.
Just a better person here.
Brings more to your perspective,
that's for sure.
Opens up your perspective big time.
Yeah.
So there's people,
if what you're saying is correct and there's someone right now on the fence,
should I or should I not?
Maybe I should.
Maybe I won't like it.
I don't know.
It's sweaty dudes.
I don't just go train goal for free.
Yes.
Try the one day.
You can even,
I would even say go try the one day with it.
I mean I would never recommend having a defensive attitude towards it.
I would never recommend that.
But Brett,
it's better than not going to give yourself an attitude of like,
hey,
if you don't like it,
go prove that it sucks.
Yes,
exactly right.
Prove.
Prove that it sucks.
Yes,
exactly.
Ranch.
But when you fail to prove that it sucks and you realize that it is awesome,
it is awesome.
You can be like,
Dang,
where am I needed g and best gs.
Not only in America.
In the world.
Yeah.
Factually worldwide they are made in America are from,
they are from origin.
So origin main.com is where you can get your geese.
There's other stuff on their flash cards on there for Nogi Rash Guard for the
Jujitsu.
Also,
when you're not on the [inaudible] Matt and you still want to have the comfort
and the glory of American made products.
I mean we're talking a lot about freedom today.
Why not get a pair of jeans that were made under the umbrella of freedom right
here in the United States of America up in the great state of Maine,
grown here in America.
Right?
Why would you not do that?
So I want to check out genes,
checkout tee shirts,
checkout all that clothing.
And then also if you want some supplements for your body,
nutritional supplements,
if you,
if you're working out all the time,
you're going to need some joint warfare.
A joint warfare helps your joints.
Krill oil also help your joints.
And actually both those things also help your just overall life.
Yes,
get on those.
Discipline and discipline.
Go discipline is for me to pre mission situation.
It's not,
but don't get it confused with the traditional preworkout stimulant that gets
you all amped up by some eyes was reading someone saying,
Oh,
I don't want to take a pre workout before Jujitsu.
Correct.
As a pre workout and I don't recommend taking a pre workout before Jujitsu this,
this has 15 milligrams of caffeine because that's what people worry about.
My is going to be pumping,
right?
No,
this is gonna.
It's gonna get you cognitively and physically ready to rock and roll.
Once climbed and and discipline go,
which is the pill form when you need,
when you need imagine.
Okay.
You know what you feel like when you're in the zone,
right?
Yes.
Just imagine you could get in the zone like basically on demand.
Sure.
That's what's happening here with discipline.
Go.
Yeah.
You can feel it and it gets you in the zone.
It's it.
You know what trips me out is I'll take discipline.
I was going,
you know,
speak with a company.
I'm going to be sitting down,
there's 20 like smart leaders in a room from a company that got a lot of stuff
going on,
big company.
And I go in and I've got,
I gotta be honest,
I'm like juiced up on like three discipline go,
you're ready to go.
But I get in there and I'm,
I'm,
I'm just feeling great,
right?
And I get out of there and I'm like thinking to myself,
I'm like,
you know,
I should have recorded that.
There's no,
I'm not kidding.
There's times where I go to,
I've worked with a client and I think,
man,
I should have recorded that.
I have do phone calls,
sometimes a client and I'm like,
I should've just recorded my end sir.
Because I'm telling people really important things about planning,
about leadership,
about decision making and it's getting lost.
I mean,
I told 20 people,
what about everyone else?
I'm thinking of myself and I come out of there and I think to myself,
I'm like,
yeah,
I was just in the zone.
I wonder what happened.
I'm like,
Oh,
I took three discipline goes and I'm ready to rock.
And Roll.
That's what happened.
So anyways,
it's flooded.
That sounds like you're like all frickin like yourself.
Like oh my God.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I know.
I'm so good at what I do and I felt like I cheated.
It actually makes sense though.
You know like why you say when you're in the zone,
right?
And you said,
you know like I don't know even like in my case,
like you're from my friend who asked me like a question and then I'll be like,
wait and I'll kind of cover like all the aspects of the question like all
fluidly and I'm like,
Dang.
I kind of said that kind of good right there.
Not that I'm a great speaker,
nothing like that,
but I'm just saying,
given the question he asked at the certain time and the way I answered that
really feel good about it or really feel good about it.
That's kind of like what you get into.
You know,
like when you take the discipline,
it's like it's just,
you just kind of flow with it.
I'm like,
like surfing or something.
I started to get a little like,
is it possible to become addicted to that feeling?
Well,
depends on what kind of quote unquote shit ain't talking to my cousin.
There's psychological addiction.
Yeah.
Like that's a thing.
So yeah.
Anyways,
that's the discipline and that's the discipline go.
Um,
and then we got,
we got some milk and you know what is,
sure.
Yeah.
It's more luck.
Happens to have 22 grams of protein.
Yeah.
By the way,
and by the way,
MIT is my favorite kind of flavor overall in the world.
And I have not had mint since I got strawberries at my house.
I gotta be straight up now.
I'll get over it in a little while,
you know what I mean?
But right now it's just the hype is still behind the Silverado,
the strawberries,
strawberries,
slayer.
How good is it anyways?
Yeah,
that's that.
Get the Malke get the warrior monk kid for your kids or your kid milk.
It's a,
that comes in strawberry and chocolate.
Once again,
the strawberries,
unreal the chocolates.
Fine.
It's good.
Your kids will like it.
The strawberry,
they'll be coming back for more.
Yeah,
right.
it's dessert.
And then of course you've got Jocko white tea,
which is good for you.
It tastes good.
And the most important thing is that it gives you an 8,000 pound dead lift,
which is not Jabie.
No,
it is 100% guaranteed.
Like 100% yeah.
Like every single person that's ever had it has got an 80,000 pound up.
Yeah.
So we're good there.
Give that a try if you want.
Yeah,
yeah.
Big Time.
All that stuff that we just talked about.
Is it origin main.com if you want it,
you know,
and the t we offer the tea as well.
Where on our store?
Oh,
I didn't know we had a store Jellco you do have the store?
It's called Jocko store.
Anyway.
Yes.
So yeah,
Dakota store called Jocko store.com this is where you can get a bunch of rash
guards,
t shirts,
hats,
stickers,
pretty much anything that you would use stickers in there.
Right now we have stickers,
bumper stickers.
They couldn't have,
everyone knows that.
Yeah,
it could be sold out and we don't know.
Tell Jesse Jesse,
we'll get them into game.
Not,
oh the decals.
Okay.
See the difference between bumper stickers and decals?
We have decals.
Oh well those are like more legitimate stickers.
Okay,
cool.
That's the ones I like.
Yes.
I need to be intent on that level.
Yeah,
pretty much anything if you want to represent,
you know the discipline equals freedom.
Like concept,
you know a guy and this is just,
you should know this.
I'm a guy there was,
I was speaking at an event and they were talking about like,
Oh God,
we got some guys that are going to wear your tee shirt.
You know.
And I was like,
oh that's awesome.
And the guy was talking,
he was kind of,
I don't know,
he just had a look on his face like,
like I was like saying,
oh it's so awesome that guys are wearing,
you know,
the t shirt.
And so I said to him,
I said,
it's awesome because like that's how the podcast is supported.
It's like when you buy a tee shirt,
that's how the podcast is supported.
So it is cool and it's appreciated if you get a tee shirt or a hat or a rash
guard or whatever from the Jocko store cause then we can have the podcast.
Yeah.
And the good,
the good support.
Support you big tent.
Good news about this too though.
It's not like the shirts and I said this from the beginning.
I think this was kind of the goal when you know,
when you make sure it's you produce.
Sure.
Yeah.
It's,
it seems obvious to be like Oh yeah let's just get some shirts.
No,
no,
no.
I've made it a point to get like literally the shirts that like that I wear or
that in which are we're proving cause I made sure it's before in the past
actually had been making shirts since I was like six years old to be honest with
you.
So I find when,
where are you making sure it's when you're six years old.
Calais.
But let me explain that a little bit so you get shit.
Well cause when I wasn't like you will run into silkscreen operation.
No,
but when you're six years old,
yes.
My mom is your mom was making sure to when you were six years old.
Well you kind of filtered to us too.
So they did a airbrush.
They did silk screen.
They didn't calling.
I want to see some kid pictures of you with an airbrush tee shirt.
Unicorn,
rainbow,
Shaka,
Shaka.
Maybe they're mainly a lot of flowers.
A lot of that kind of,
it was on quiet.
So there,
there is a,
she worked at a place called tropical shirts.
Yes.
Quiet a little y.
Um,
Brittany,
they shared a building with like a can of pineapple cannery and they make sure
it was really interesting.
Anyway,
that's where we learned nonetheless.
The point is I didn't get some just random cheap with cheap his shirt.
I've got wearable shirts as many people and when I say many,
I mean more than I can.
I can't recollect like the last five people.
It's actually like,
it's actually a lot of people.
Yeah.
People tell me this too.
That it's the most like their favorite shirt to wear because it fits so good.
It's like the soft,
the material.
It's not just like some rigid thing,
you know they're good,
they're quick.
It's quality stuff is what I'm saying,
so you know beneficial in Jocko,
store.com hay and also speaking,
the podcast is subscribe to this podcast if you haven't already.
If you will subscribe to it.
Then you just click a button that says subscribe and you did it.
You achieved the goal of the day you subscribed to the podcast and the more
subscribers we get that no,
whatever.
Subscribed to the podcast,
get in the game.
The warrior kid podcast as well.
That one's coming out a little bit infrequently right now,
but we are getting them out.
I'm working on another one right now.
There's plenty of lessons in there for everyone from Uncle Jake and then you can
also get some more of your kids soap from Irish oaks ranch.com
also we have a youtube channel.
Yeah,
good channel.
I think if you're interested in the video version,
that's mainly what it's for.
Also Act,
there's some excerpts on there that we put out so you don't have to necessarily
listen to the whole thing every single time.
You see,
whenever I meet someone that has a commute [inaudible] more than 40 minutes to
work and from work,
they're completely caught up on the podcast.
Yeah.
When I meet someone that has a commute that's like 10 minutes,
they're like,
oh you're putting out these podcasts,
you're fast.
And I say,
well listen harder.
You know,
cause you can Sun Sun some apps,
you can play it at 1.5 or whatever,
two,
two times of speed.
I don't know that.
I would recommend that I've accidentally,
you know,
sometimes you accidentally press the button and it'll go faster.
It's kind of weird,
but if you're trying to rush it,
you can try and you also can,
you can get used to it to get used to it.
But then the thing is with me a lot of times,
obviously I speak really slow with big giant pauses.
I'm sorry.
That's just the way I talk.
But then also sometimes I speak really quickly and put my words together and
they kind of flow out.
If you are listening to this right now at 2.0 speed,
you'd be in a world of hurt trying to understand what I was talking about,
so that's when you got to be able to get back to that button,
hammer it down and get you to slow back down to a normal speed of 1.0 I'm pretty
sure,
but yeah,
either way.
Youtube,
yes,
Youtube.
It's a,
we do have youtube channels,
so yeah,
check that out if you're interested in now also psychological warfare,
if you didn't know what that is,
to help with tracks.
Chocolate tracks getting us all through our moments of weakness.
If they become prevalent,
which they do from time to time.
They do weigh less now by the way,
but you know those are the,
those are chuck on.
Whenever you get an MP three you can get the psychological warfare album.
That's an audio.
It's an audio reminder reminder.
If you want a visual reminder,
you can go to flip side,
canvas.com
run by my brother Dakota Meyer.
He was on this podcast number one 15
he makes things that you can look at.
Just say good things on them to remind you of what you should be doing.
He just made a new one that says all your excuses are lies.
Yeah,
I saw them.
Those,
there's no a not all fancy cause there's nothing fancy about all their excuses
are lies.
It's simple for the simplicity element.
Yes.
So yeah,
check out flip side games.
Dot.
Come get some stuff to hang on your walls.
Yes.
And also made under the umbrella of freedom here in America.
Yes sir.
It is big time also on it,
on it.com/jocko this is where you can get workout gear.
Some warrior bars.
Here's the thing,
I haven't been talking about the worry of bars,
but those warrior bars are like key.
They're,
they're uh,
they're good to have on the standby scenario.
Oh yeah.
And even like,
that's like a semi daily,
put a semi dailies that every other day.
Semi daily.
It's not necessarily mean.
Yeah.
Semi Day.
Well,
my frequency with these warrior bars,
protein packed food,
they're not like,
like,
you know how little power bars,
it's not like that.
It's like a protein meat anyway.
It's called the worry about anyway,
that's every other day I would say.
It's like,
I don't even like to use the word snack because it doesn't feel like a snack.
it's like a hybrid snack slash meal protein ish.
Anyway,
nonetheless,
there's a lot of cool stuff on there.
A kettle bells on there.
All right.
You say artistic kettlebells,
even though they are artistic,
but I feel like it doesn't capture the glory of the kettlebells.
Nonetheless,
primal bills,
legend bells.
That's where I get them.
What do they call the star wars bells.
Oh,
they call them space bells are,
uh,
I don't think they have a name for the group yet,
but yes,
I just got the Darth Vader one didn't come in yet.
Oh,
like a storm trooper.
Darth Vader.
There's a Boba Fett one,
which is dope,
but I'm going to get all three.
I'll
report back to the less anyway,
on it.com/chocolate this Ricky get this good stuff.
A lot of good stuff.
I've got a bunch of books.
The book to order right now is where the warrior kid three where there's a will,
that book comes out May 28th so we're talking you better order it now cause it's
probably going to sell out you,
I'll have to print more.
Don't forget about the first two and then the first two.
Yep.
We got way of the warrior kid.
Okay.
From wimpy to warrior and then ABC away.
And then you got marked mission in Mars mission is your daughter's favorite?
Correct.
If she sleeps with it.
Hmm.
Strange.
Yeah.
Not a stuffed down won't by the way,
it's a book.
The hard cover book,
not the most physically cozy,
which I'm not opposed to physically go,
but yes.
Sleeps with it.
Yeah.
Her favorite books,
J.
Dot.
Yes.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
So that's where the where your kid and Mark's mission teaching good
things to children and they needed these days.
And also you've got Mikey and the dragons.
That one is for a little bit younger crowd.
And then on top of that,
of course we've got the discipline equals freedom field manual for which is for
everyone teaches you how to get after it.
The audio is on iTunes and Google play and Amazon music and an extreme ownership
dichotomy of leadership,
which I wrote with my brother Leif Babin.
You can get these books too,
learn about leadership and you can do also get these books and give them to the
people that work for you or the people that you work for so that you all become
better leaders.
On top of that,
we have echelon front.
That's my leadership consultancy in what we do is we solve problems through
leadership.
If you've got a company,
if you've got a business,
you've got a team and you got problems at that team,
the problems are due to one thing and one thing only and that's leadership.
So if you want to get those problems fixed at your team,
go to echelon front.com we've got the muster Chicago sold out already.
In fact,
it might be on during this,
uh Oh no,
we're listening to it right now.
So Chicago and then we've got Denver,
September 19th and 20th we got Sydney,
December 4th and fifth extreme ownership.com if you want to come,
they're all going to sell out.
So try and sign up early.
Otherwise you're going to miss it.
The one in Sydney,
by the way,
I think we,
I think the place that we got down there,
I want to say it's less than 400 people.
So that place is going to sell out quick.
Not to mention our first time going to Australia for a muster.
So it's going to get crazy quick.
So if you want to come try and sign up brother
Eif online,
this is online training.
If you can't come,
if you can't come to the muster,
if you can't come to the muster or let's say,
and this is the reason we created it,
is because we work with companies that have 62,000 employees and they say,
Hey Jocko,
can you train all of our employees there around the world?
And I say,
no,
I can't.
No,
I actually say,
standby,
let me talk to you in a month.
And then it's,
hey,
we created and it didn't take them out.
That took a lot longer than a month.
Took us about it.
Took us about nine months to get it out.
But it's online,
interactive leadership training.
Get your whole organization on the same page and if you're an individual,
you want it,
you can get it here.
It's ETF online.com and we've got f Overwatch where we're taking special
operations in combat aviation leaders off the battlefield and putting them into
companies so that they can help those companies lead.
And a lot of times people think,
well,
what are some,
what are some uh,
special forces guy going to know about
manufacturing?
Trust me,
you put them in there.
It's not about manufacturing.
He'll learn about the manufacturing,
but what he's going to know,
what he knows how to do right now is he knows how to lead and he's going to turn
that organization around.
So that's f overwatch.com
okay.
Where we can get you your leadership also,
we're on the Inter webs,
which is also called the Internet by the way.
Hmm.
I already knew that.
Nonetheless,
Twitter,
Instagram,
Facebook.
I met Echo,
which was that last one face bull plot.
I'm at echocharles chocolates at Jocko Willink and thanks to everyone out there
that
they've went out there that has fought and does fight for our freedom,
standing up against these
evil regimes in the world and putting your life on the line to defend,
to defend our ideal,
which is freedom.
And here at home,
thanks to police and law enforcement and firefighters and paramedics and EMT
empties and dispatchers and correctional officers and border patrol's secret
service and all the other first responders.
Thanks to you as well for keeping us safe here at home and to everyone else out
there.
Remember this code that we talked about,
remember what it meant to people and remember the will that it instilled in
those people,
uh,
will so strong that they faced death without fear.
And then remember the will,
the will that overcame that code
was the will of freedom.
Okay?
The will that says,
I will bow down to no man,
the will to stand up no matter what kind of evil death cult there was that
attacked and tried to enslave the world.
That evil was overcome by the strength of freedom and the will
to get up
and no matter what,
get after it.
Then until next time,
this is echo and Jocko
out.